[Music]
um so very excited today to be able to
meet with uh Martin and Walter vi from
what's up Prof uh you guys have had a
huge impact on my own personal testimony
and um also on so many others uh we're
here at ASI um so first of all I just
just wanted to say how have you enjoyed
your time here at ASI and um what is it
that you guys are doing here with your
ministry what is it that you wanted to
talk about while you're here at ASR well
we're here Elijah because we want to
showcase what we do our focus is on
truth and truth is particularly in the
framework of present truth yes what's
essential for the time we are living in
and that's the Three Angels messages
that have to go to the world because
that's God's final call God's final
warning to the world and it is a call of
love right mhm that's right but uh if
you don't accept it there are
consequences so what Clash of Minds is
all about is putting political and
religious events into the context of
Bible prophecy and preaching to the
world where we are standing in the
Stream of time what decisions must be
made and uh yeah
excellent excellent I'm I'm I'm excited
to get into all of those topics a little
bit deeper um I'm here uh with Heartland
College uh we are a school that is based
on um true education the blueprint for
Education um including practical
knowledge as well as preparing
missionaries to go out into the world
and spread the Three Angels messages as
we understand them um we have a wellness
center and we promote the uh principles
of new start as well um and so all of
the things that you're saying are very
relevant to to what we're doing over
there now I understand you reacted to a
call so when you reacted to this call
which is basically based on the Three
Angels messages that's right come out of
them my people yes tell us a little bit
about that so uh I was working in Los
Angeles as a film and television actor
um I had just had a film that had
several Oscar nominations and I was
playing a a a fairly well-known I was
playing Cashes Clay so somebody that a
lot of people knew it had a lot of
critical to claim and I had been working
in film and television as an actor in h
in in La for about 10 years
professionally I was just taking off uh
with my career it was a big breakout um
but I I was attending the 7th Day
Adventist Church but I didn't know our
message I had read the Bible I believed
in the Sabbath um but I didn't listen to
Ellen White the church was kind of
divided people with some people in the
Church would say yeah you should
definitely read it other people would
say oh you don't need that that's old
fashion yes yeah or even you know I
don't listen to that stuff and you know
so for me as a person coming into the
church I was like if you guys aren't
even sure about it I don't want to have
anything to do with it um and so I I I
would go to church on Sabbath but I
never called myself an Adventist really
um I just I believed in the Sabbath I
believed in the
Bible what happened was Co hit and about
a while before when I was still living
in Vancouver a friend of mine had given
me the total Onslaught series and I had
watched it about 5 minutes of it and I
said this guy's crazy tot I said this
guy's nuts I threw it away I said I gave
it back to my buddy is his name was
Israel I said Israel thanks uh I think I
think you you know this is a little bit
much for me I'm good and then covid
happened a while later years later and I
was sitting in my apartment in Studio
City I was looking out my window on
Tunga uh Boulevard and I saw military
truck military truck military truck then
I'm looking at the news I see Naomi
Campbell in a hazmat suit at LAX I'm
going I'm I'm looking at Hollywood
there's no cars in Hollywood yeah on
Highland AV you know I said this is
unbelievable at the same time I'm doing
a lot of meetings with uh Spielberg's
executive uh companies with Tyler
Perry's companies with a lot of
different highle production people
because they want to work with they want
to see if there's projects they can work
with me on now that I had this film that
broke out and you know not to say
anything about those gentlemen in
particular but I spoke to quite a few
Executives and the messaging that they
were saying to me in our meetings was
all about promoting uh a satanic agenda
it was always about um life after death
eternal life um uh Masonic
imagery uh you know one yeah I won't
even name the project cuz I don't want
to get anybody in trouble but there was
everything about it there was people
that were doing Sun worshiping Cults and
wanted me to come there were friends of
mine that were Freemasons that were
promoting Freemasonry in our interviews
blatantly and so I said man that stuff
that that guy
said is true I'm living it I'm seeing it
in my own life that this guy was telling
the truth and I couldn't remember who
you were so I started looking I'm like
conspiracy theory German Adventist guy
you know I'm like trying to find you and
I found you and then I started I watched
uh total Onslaught in 3 days I watched
all 36 I just was like one after the
next after the next and I said oh man
this is real and then I had a choice to
make because I I'd been working so long
for my career and I and I finally had my
hands on it you know and I was like yes
and then at the same time I'm like but
this this message is the truth and Jesus
really is coming and I have an
opportunity that I you know I I won't
get another opportunity to do this and
so um um and so at that moment I I was
like you know what profit a man to gain
the whole world and lose his soul I
believe Jesus is coming I believe the
message was true um I started listening
to my pastor Dr o because that came up
after I watched you uh you've been to
State Line 7day Venice church so you
know Dr o um and then after that I
listened to both of you guys and both of
you guys were talking about Ellen White
so much I said well I trust these guys
and they keep talking about Ellen White
let me I should give her a chance you
know and so I I read adventus home first
and that touched me on a really personal
level and then I read great controversy
and after that I said you know this is
this is undeniable she's a prophet these
things could not have been written by a
human being uh just under their own
wisdom under their own understanding
impossible impossible um and so yeah so
that's how the call came to me um and
then God drew me into ministry as I left
do you know how glad I am to see that
because you are a person that can
influence
minds and you had to make a choice right
yes and that choice was salvational
mhm and you see all the people out there
trapped in systems yes and the
motivation that I had in making total
Onslaught was not to be Sensational like
many people believe but to Enlighten
those that are trapped in those systems
to realize what they're trapped in and
to make a decision to come out praise
God well I mean I can tell you
personally it was affected me I'd love
to say my sister Bianca she'll be happy
that I mentioned her and my best friend
Serene knight uh are two other people
that were you know uh saw the videos it
they saw that it was the truth and they
made a total shift um you know and moved
into Ministry moved out of the world
that they were in uh got baptized uh and
are now present TR 7th Day Adventists um
so you know uh uh incredibly grateful
for the work God did through that but
tell us how you are going to go forward
and use the message to so I'm studying
pastoral evangelism at Heartland right
now and health uh and I'm my goal is to
use those things to do missionary work
that's what our school is based on um is
developing missionaries because right
now there's so few people that are
willing to go out into the mission field
and share this message with the world um
but I wanted to also talk about you know
some of the things that you've been
covering we've been seeing the world
right now with what happened with Donald
Trump just recently uh the assassination
attempt Joe Biden dropping out and
camela Harris beginning to run um to me
those things are very closely tied in
with all of the project
2025 uh information that we saw not long
ago um either one of you just can you
please talk about how important it is
that we get this message out right now
when we're seeing these events
culminating and wrapping up right before
our eyes
you know what our church is asleep isn't
it it's
asleep what is our prophetic picture our
prophetic picture is that the world will
move back into a situation like it was
in the Middle Ages where the church WIll
dictate morality by law that is
Unthinkable under a Biden Harris system
of governance exactly but prophecy says
that it will happen that's right so what
must happen Christians must be
galvanized into believing that they have
to take control or the world will go to
pot that's right so in the hegelian
dialectic how do you achieve this let's
say there's a master Puppeteer behind
the scenes and he's trying to shift the
Mind into a synthesis where people will
say enough is enough we have to dictate
morality so let's use some shock
tactics let's put a message out there I
will empower the church from day one who
said that Donald Trump said that that's
right and you will not have to vote
again once you have done that that sends
a powerful message out into the world MH
at the same time let's attack
Christianity from every single an angle
let's bring in the work world let's
bring in the transgender
let's bring in all of these issues and
let's use the Paris Olympics to really R
the Christian World up and say Christian
World stand together enough is enough is
that mindset happening in the world
absolutely and I don't think it's ironic
that it was in I don't think it's
coincidence that was in Paris of course
of all places that they have these
images being where did it start in 1798
the whole um IND with uh what was it
secularism where where they secularism
came out yes that's right in was in
France absolutely reu which is the basis
of the French Revolution and the whole
ideology of do what thou Wilt as the
whole of the law right that's right
that's right now if you want to create
sympathy for that
cause then uh any event whether it be
real or whether it be unreal that
cements this mindset
would be very useful so let's say you
have this assassination attempt mhm what
did that do to the mindset of many
people didn't it create a bond of
sympathy for sure even people I mean
Facebook's um Mark Zuckerberg he said
even he had a comment favorable towards
Trump after that so seen as a liberal
but obviously the devil understands the
the how martyr dism works because Mars
were some of the reasons why he wasn't
able to overc the church and so he
understands that when there's a mar
people are going to have sympathy and
empathy for them so he's trying to use
that to his Advantage now now we don't
know who's going to win the election no
and we are not going to favor one or the
other but it's very interesting to me
that the think tank around
225 yeah has been literally saying that
these things have to be implemented from
day one right right and they also said
they hope that it will be a bloodless
Revolution yeah they hope it so if the
left capitulates it will be a bloodless
Revolution but they also said if the
left wins there will be a
revolution wow there were some by the
way it's interesting if the one wins and
it does come to a civil mhm conflict
within the nation it will move in the
direction of Prophecy whether the left
winds or whether the right wins if the
right wins well then these things
including Sunday law are on the cards
from day one because that stands in
Project 2025 that's right I think page
581 so left or right with or without
conflict with or without blood Bible
prophecy will be fulfilled and that's
the message
and the climate and the atmosphere that
you have in the world right now MH is so
open and conducive to this MH that
whether they achieve it by The Ballot or
whether they achieve it by force that's
where they want to go that's right so
Ellen White is clear when she talks
about Civil War when she talks about the
Nations that we see currently in
conflict that the the separation between
those who have and those who don't and
how those who are hungry and in need of
food and money are going to rise up and
so we see these things are going to take
place in we're going to have economic
chaos that's right doesn't Matthew 24
say that already absolutely so let's say
that the table has been set and the food
is on the table all we have to do is
partake of it right that's right and
many people are sitting at the table
already ready to eat um I did want to
talk as well we you know speaking of the
church you said that there is sleep
Revelation says that we are the leoan
church we're lukewarm um there have been
some very public statements um and I
don't know if you want to cover this you
can always cut it out later if you want
to but uh recently Ben Carlson was on
Tucker Carlson he made some statements
number one that there's nothing in the
Constitution that speaks about the
separation of church and state uh he
said that Donald Trump was chosen by God
to save America and he said that we
should include the Ten Commandments in
our school systems and highly alluded to
the idea that we should include them in
our institutions in America in general
these are things that go directly
against What Spirit of Prophecy says we
should be doing exactly as the most
prominent probably Seventh Day Adventist
in the world most well recognized um I
would love to know what your thoughts
are not just on him but on adventism as
a whole and why is it that we're letting
go you know I think uh Elder Ted Wilson
was saying hold fast was his message why
are we letting go of these truths just
as we see them
fulfilling you know it's like
ecumenism some people believe that by
being within the ecumenical system you
can influence the thinking of the
parties within that
system uh it's the same within the
political sphere some Believe by being
part and parcel of the political sphere
you can influence the thinking of that
sphere but history has shown that the
opposite is true that's right it is more
likely to adopt the mindset of those
you're trying to reach than to change
the mindset M and elen white gives very
clear counsel that we should not be
involved in politics so I'm not talking
uh addressing let's say I'm not
addressing the the mindset or the
mentality of the people that choose to
be involved in those things I'm just
saying the council is that we
shouldn't so that's Point number one
point number two when you talk about the
Commandments and certain states have of
course now mandated that and they're
hoping it goes to the Supreme Court why
do they wanted to go to the Supreme
Court because they want the backing of
the Supreme Court to say that it's not
against church and state that's right so
once you introduce those things then you
have to ask yourself the next question
which 10
Commandments the biblical ones that's
right or the paper ones that's right and
there's a vast difference huge yeah now
what is the document in 2025 say Martin
it will default to Sunday so that's it
will default to Sunday even though they
recognize that people keep different
sabbaths MH the statement is within that
document it will default to Sunday yes
have you seen coler's uh prophetic chart
yes in coe's chart it speaks very
clearly about how the mark of the beast
will come in phases and it won't be
something that is just immediately
pushed on similar to what we saw in 2020
um it'll be something that is encouraged
and then something that is uh pushed and
then something that is demanded and then
something that is enforced um and so
we're seeing that with with project 2025
they said oh some concessions will be
made for the Sabbath but we know that as
things progress more and more based on
prophecy that that's not going to be
maintained um I did want to ask you as
well we've seen these conflicts going
around the world with Ukraine and Russia
we're seeing what's happening in Israel
right now uh I have a an article here
from um our Magazine on our campus last
generation magazine that says all eyes
on Israel can you talk a little bit
about the false prophecies that we're
seeing and the false fire that we're
seeing in terms of Revival and why
people are confused about what's really
happening happening in
Israel
yes
now Jesus said your house will be left
to you desolate yes that means there
will be no more on the political level a
recognition of the function of Israel as
a nation your house is desolate if you
are in Christ you are Abraham's seed and
as according to the promise in other
words there's been a shift from literal
Israel to spiritual Israel all those
that are in Christ are Abraham seed M
and the church from a local level which
is the type moved to the international
level every tribe Nation tongue and
people and the church is
distributed
everywhere ye are the temple of the
Living God there's no need for another
Temple God is building a spiritual house
built out of Living Stones that's what
the Bible teaches so the attack that
will come from the King of the North MH
against God's people against Israel is
against those that keep the Commandments
and hold to the testimony of Jesus
that's right that will be the attack and
it's an attack in every nation tribe and
tongue and people so it has to be a
universal influence MH to switch it to a
local level you can watch for your
salvation to unfold on
television yeah you going say all right
this nation is going to attack that
nation and therefore this is the end of
the world and there's no preparation in
your heart for what is coming wasn't
that the mistake that Israel made when
they didn't recognize Christ that's
right they wanted a temporal Kingdom
they wanted to be ex exed as the nation
that rules the world and that's exactly
what dominionism is about within the
Christian world and what the Evangelical
dispensational view is about Israel
that's right exactly the same thing
that's right and if your eyes are there
you're missing the point because the
Bible says you're not looking there
you're looking at the Beast out of the
sea and you're looking at the Beast out
of the earth Revelation 13 you're
looking at the implementation of the
mark of the beast and that's certainly
not going to happen in literal Jerusalem
it's going to happen universally there
might be things happening
there that's not the focus so all of
these things might be coming true and
might happen but that does not mean that
your focus has to go
there there's a little book this Rome's
challenge please do you remember this
book Rome's challenge is a reprint of
what the Catholic mirror wrote when
there was an attempt to introduce Sunday
legislation in 1888 MH and they
blatantly state that the Sunday is the
mark of their Authority yes and that the
only ones who do not see any relevance
in it within the Christian sphere of the
seventh day
Adventists and that all Protestants are
actually Bowing in reverence to the
command of the Holy Roman Catholic
Church their words not our words so this
challenge is almost like the first Siege
of
Jerusalem they could have implemented
Sunday law in 1888 with a Blair bill but
there was a
withdrawal now they're coming with Major
Force to do it a second time one article
after the other coming out of
Evangelical pens secular pens and and
Roman Catholic pens mhm that we need the
Implement implementation of a Sunday law
that's right and why is it essential to
them because it is attached to their
Authority in religious matters that's
right and their Authority they claim
supersedes the authority of God himself
that's right that's what they say it's
an arrogance yeah I it's interesting you
brought that up with the Catholic church
because another one of the things that
uh Dr Carson had said was we need to
return to the principles of the common
good the exact words and I said that's a
jesal thing exactly I was so amazed all
those words that you mentioned earlier
that was mentioned by him that's a very
ecumenical State there's very ecumenical
statements that's let's
stop Making Waves because we all want to
be in harmony with each other but then
that comes at a compromise always so the
Seventh Adventist message has to be
watered down to be acceptable to the the
rest of the people and that's why it's
always a problem when we speak against
the the Beast if you take the
Commandment remember the Sabbath
day the is a definite
article now a definite article is always
attached to one
thing if we say a cat bumped over the
flower pot it could be any cat the cat
did it that's the one with a brown spot
on the nose it's very
definite so if there is a the Sabbath
but there are two in the world now the
one in the Bible and the one within the
papacy which one is the true one one why
is it
important because the one claims I am
your creator I'm your Redeemer this is
the sign that you will acknowledge me as
such you will keep my Sabbath day verily
my sabbaths you shall keep that's right
because it is a sign between me and you
that I am the one that sanctifies you
right that's right that's the one and
the other one says no I'm the one that
gives you rest I'm the one that will
bring the common good I'm the one that
will bring peace on this Earth we will
have a synchronized day of rest and I am
the authority behind it aren't you
choosing between two
opposites yes absolutely is there a
compromise that's possible there can be
compromise and what's at stake it is
God's God's Authority in your life and
your acknowledgment of that so the day
becomes the means to tell the world
where you stand who you accept as your
Authority I I'll I'll ask a question is
it possible to serve Jesus in the common
good no no because is not for the common
good he's for his good that's right he's
standing for a principle which is alien
to the world that's right that's right
it's interesting I was reading Ellen
White just recently and she was saying
that when you see the union of church
and state the exact words that that is
going to be the formation of the image
to of the image of the Beast corre and
so there there's no question about
whether or not we should be supporting
Union of church and state that is the
image of the beast that's is uh Trump
for the union of jurges absolutely oh
for sure is the head of the Congress in
absolutely yeah Mike Jones yes yes Mike
Johnson right Johnson Johnson yeah he's
vice president what about the governors
in the world what about the governor of
the state of Florida what about the
governor of the state of Pennsylvania
aren't they for the union of church and
state absolutely so they're dominionists
yes but the Kingdom of Heaven is
something that Jesus sets up at his com
and not something that we set up priet
to is coming absolutely absolutely let
me switch gears for a second um we at
Heartland again we're very adamant about
preaching the health message um we have
a belief in evidence-based Natural
Health um and also we have uh a focus on
cancer treatment we have a 17-day cancer
treatment program um recently we
released our magazine do you need a
health Revolution and we've had uh great
speakers like Barbara O'Neal come to our
campus and talk about it I know you're
passionate about the health message um
you've used it in your own life you've
promoted it why is it so important right
now that people have a health Revolution
and what is it that we have as Seventh
Day Adventist that the world
needs the third Angel's message has a
right
arm and that is the health message now
the health message is linked to the
principles that God introduced in
humanity from day one of the
creation and he gave a particular life
lifestyle to the creatures that he
created and that is the lifestyle that
he calls you back to and that is the
lifestyle that he promised the
Israelites none of the diseases which I
placed upon the
Egyptians so when he calls you he also
changes your lifestyle he did it to the
Israelites he is consistent because
Jesus Christ the same yesterday and
forever therefore in the end time he
will also bring God's people back to
that which was there in the beginning MH
and the question is where's the
enemy is the enemy something that we
have to shoot
at like uh the diseases and the vaccines
and all of these things that we need
that we have to shoot at or should we
protect ourselves through our
lifestyle if we come to the conclusion
that God has put a certain mechanism in
place within us that protects us from
disease if we obey him upon these
principles then that is a very important
point because not only does it affect
your health it affects your
mind and uh when the Israelites of old
rebelled against God's Health message he
says he sent a leanness into the
soul there was an emptiness there that
couldn't be filled so he wants to redeem
you not only spiritually but he wants to
redeem you physically as well he wants
you to have a healthy mind in order to
make cognitive healthy
decisions so the health message is
absolutely Paramount in the last days
Healthy Mind healthy decisions and if
possible it's for Ministries it's a very
good thing if you can incorporate that
in the ministry in one way or the
another we at Clash of Minds we've also
got a right the right arm now in a form
uh we've got Varity center it's also a
health center that we've started
excellent excellent with all do exactly
the same that you guys want to do it and
it has to be done worldwide yes lights
all over the world is what is the
message that Alan white gave that if you
be found doing this you will be you will
hear the words well done good and
faithful servant if when Jesus comes he
will find us busy with doing the gospel
and the right arm praise God you cannot
separate M the health message from the
gospel no Jesus healed the physical as
well as the spiritual nature he said
your sins are forgiven get up and
walk so the two always go together and
does the devil have a counter Fe
absolutely yes he does he has the
medical system The Establishment system
the drug drugs and the vaccines and all
these things what does he do does he
enforce it oh yes by mandates all right
by mandate does Jesus ever use mandates
no so has anybody got the right within a
Christian system to enforce something
that is linked to your conscience
absolutely not let's leave it at that
let's leave it at that um I'd wanted to
give you guys an opportunity with Clash
of Minds um what are some of the
projects that you guys are moving
forward with what's next for what's up
Prof and what other uh resources are you
here at ASI uh showing and allowing
people to have access to and how can
they support your ministry Martin well
I've already mentioned Varity Health
Center that we are we've got on then we
also um getting on with a uh
Evangelistic school that will be
starting in uh October uh five we course
intense course that goes up from uh
growing your own food three Angels
messages how to go and spread it to
people out there uh the dangers music
everything in five week in five weeks
and that will probably be on a maybe
quarterly uh level next year and we
probably hope hopefully will continue
with that is that in South Africa or is
that online it's on South Africa we are
looking at maybe recording the and also
presenting it online there it's it's a
little bit in development stages still
but that and I I hope you do have access
to it cuz I'd love to watch it myself
yeah and the reason why we're doing it
short 5 weeks and that's it because time
is short we don't have years to tell
people they need to know what's the
essence of the Three Angels message why
is it important how do I preach it how
do I live it and then and then go and do
it absolutely you know I'll just say
this uh you know as a as a bit of a
bonus when I was looking at who wrote
the project 2025
Paul Dan he's recently stepped down and
you look at his background um he was
raised Catholic his father was uh
eulogized at a Jesuit Church um and and
went to Jesuit training from he was in
elementary catholic school high school
Catholic school and then Jesuit college
his father worked very closely um with
Dr Ben Carson he was a he was a doctor
as well at John Hopkins but you can see
that they on that side of things they
understand the time is short and they
are moving with intention um and so as
God's people it's so important that we
believe our message and that we move
with intention to share the Three Angels
messages um and not be uh lacad isical
in any in any fashion history is
confirming our prophetic view before our
eyes yes yes all right well that is
great thank you so much for this time um
I will continue to be praying for your
ministry uh uh you know it's been such a
blessing as I mentioned earlier to my
own personal life and to my own Ministry
um and so I pray that God just continues
to watch over you and protect you and to
bless your ministry and the same for you
you have a very important role to play
because you have a certain audience that
you can reach that maybe nobody else can
may God use you richly thank you God
bless thanks um so uh Dr V will you
please uh bless us by closing out with a
with a word of
prayer heavenly father I thank you for
the
opportunity what a wonderful opportunity
it is when you call people from
different walks of life from the media
World from the academic world from the
corporate world you bring people
together they have one passion and that
is to preach the final message of
warning to the world I pray that you
will
Empower everyone that is involved here
and will bring this message to the world
because time is short and we want to go
home bless us bless the message in
jesus' name amen amen amen
[Music]